BATMAN SUIT, T-SHIRT.
SOME THINGS ARE JUST UNIVERSAL.
>>> NOW TO THE LATEST ON THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE CDC SAYS A MORE INFECTIOUS
VARIANT FIRST IDENTIFIED IN
ENGLAND IS NOW THE MOST COMMON
COVID STRAIN IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO THAT MAY EXPLAIN WHY THE RATE
OF NEW CASES IS HOLDING FIRM AT
ABOUT 64,000 PER DAY EVEN THOUGH
NEARLY HALF OF THE U.S. ADULTS
HAVE RECEIVED ONE OR TWO DOSES
OF THE VACCINE.
CBS NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR DR.
DAVID AGUS JOINS US TO SORT IT
ALL OUT.
I THINK WE NEED A BIT OF A
REALITY CHECK HERE.
IT'S REALLY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN SAID THAT
IT'S A RACE BETWEEN THE VACCINE
AND THE VARIANT.
DO YOU SEE IT THAT WAY, TOO, AND
IF YOU DO, WHO'S WINNING THE
RACE?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
GAYLE.
YEAH, YOU KNOW, WE VACCINATED
ALMOST HALF OF ADULTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT STILL MEANS THERE ARE OVER
100 MILLION ADULTS TO GO FOR
VACCINATION.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS A
DRAMATIC RISE, PARTICULARLY
YOUNGER INDIVIDUALS, KIND OF 12
TO 19 YEARS OF AGE, ARE BECOMING
MORE AND MORE INFECTED.
SO WE'RE LETTING DOWN OUR GUARD,
AND WITH THIS NEW VARIANT, IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO SPREAD.
THIS IS RISE OF THE VARIANTS.
THIS IS OUR SEQUEL, IF YOU WILL.
AND IT IS CERTAINLY SCARY.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS FROM NOW, WE
WILL BE IN A MUCH BETTER
SITUATION WITH VACCINATIONS.
SO WE JUST HAVE TO HOLD OUR
GUARD FOR ANOTHER FEW MONTHS.
AND IT WORRIES ME BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT.
>> YEAH.
PEOPLE ARE SO COVID SICK, AS YOU
KNOW.
WE'RE SICK OF COVID, COVID IS
NOT DONE WITH US.
AND I KNOW THERE'S LIGHT AT THE
END OF THE TUNNEL, BUT WE'RE
STILL IN THE TUNNEL.
I THINK THAT'S A MESSAGE THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THINGS WHERE WE
CAN FINALLY -- I KNOW IT'S VERY
HARD TO PUT A TIME ON IT.
I GET IT.
CAN YOU GIVE SOME KIND OF TIME
FRAME, PEOPLE SAY HOLD ON, BUT
HOW MUCH LONGER?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> YEAH.
I REALLY THINK OVER THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS.
SO OVER THE NEXT TWO MONTHS, WE
ARE OPENING UP VACCINATIONS TO
EVERYONE IN THE UNITED STATES 16
YEARS AND OLDER.
AND THAT WILL MAKE A HUGE
IMPACT.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE SEEING IT NOW,
RIGHT.
WE HAVE FEWER HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND FEWER DEATHS.
OUR VULNERABLE HAVE A VERY GOOD
VACCINATION RATE.
WE'RE SEEING LARGE NUMBERS OF
CASES.
REMEMBER, THIS VIRUS DIDN'T JUST
CAUSE HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH,
IT CAUSES PROBLEMS IN ANYBODY
WHO GETS IT.
SO WE'RE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THE VIRUS, EVEN IN YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PILEDLY
SYMPTOMATIC, THEY CAN HAVE
LONG-LASTING EFFECTS.
>> NOW IT'S INCREASING IN KIDS.
YOU KNOW, KIDS USED TO BE YOU
THINK IMMUNE BUT THAT'S
CHANGING.
WHY?
>> WELL, WE'RE INDOOR SPORTS,
GETTING TOGETHER MUCH IN LARGER
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND WE ARE LETTING DOWN OUR
GUARD.
AND SO I THINK IN SCHOOL IS
APPROPRIATE, AND WE HAVE TO DO
IT SAFELY.
WE CAN'T DO EVERYTHING WE HAD
DONE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
WE REALLY NEED TO PUT RULES IN
PLACE TO STOP THE VIRUS' SPREAD
UNTIL WEEKS VACCINATE THE KIDS
WHICH WILL HOPEFULLY BE THIS
SUMMER.
HOPEFULLY 12 AND ABOVE OVER THE
NEXT MONTH OR TWO.
BUT AFT